There are so many new things
coming from the R open source
community every day.
It will be really hard to follow
the latest news about R.
R has come to define a magical
data science programming
language. To build on this,
R weekly team set out
to create the ultimate
realtime reading experience
for the R community.
R Weekly will help you
learn R every week.
Every aspect has been designed
for a clean and comfortable
reading experience.
Every Monday, R
Weekly editor will
aggregate all of the great
sources from the community
and create a clear and
simple newsletter for you.
You can visit R Weekly
website to read the latest
and historical issues.
There are also email
subscription and RSS feed.
Choose your favourite way to enjoy the
content from the entire R
universe.
R Weekly has a wide
range of content
with a comfortable and
clear user interface.
Weekly editor's picks deliver
high quality articles for you
to learn the best practices
and boost your own knowledge.
There is also a podcast.
It contains the weekly
highlights about the community.
This component works
in harmony to maintain
an exceptional reading
and listening experience.
How to contribute to R Weekly?
The editing process is
fully open source on GitHub.
Contributing to R Weekly
is as easy as editing
in a text editor.
Click at the bottom and
create a pull request.
And you will be able to show
your content to thousands
of users every week.
If you do not have
a GitHub account,
you can also use
the submit page.
The submit page is in the
header of R weekly website.
Type your link in the form
and R weekly team member
will see your link and
review your content.
How to become an R
weekly team members?
Please create several
pull requests
on GitHub to get
familiar with the process
to edit a newsletter.
And then take R Weekly
contributing survey.
We will reach out
to you very soon.
Here are some small
tips and tricks
you can do with
R Weekly website.
You can filter the links
with the filter box.
For example, search Shiny.
You can search all of the
links in the R Weekly website
from the search
box or from GitHub.
For example, you can search
ggplot2 and type the text.
When you hover on some
links, we will show
you the preview of the content.
And you will be
able to know what
you will read in the links.
You can turn on night mode.
I want to thank all of
the R Weekly team members.
They have done a really
good job on this project.
And all of our communication
is remote in our Slack.
I want to thank all of
R Weekly patrons,
they have been supporting this
project for a very long time.
Hope you will enjoy
the R Weekly project,
and see you every Monday.